5 44 on your friday morning what's cool
at school well in an increasingly
divided world students at hayes
elementary are learning that kindness
pays off literally pta vice president
beth newett explains a fundraiser where
the kids aren't selling anything
each student registers online and then
is able to send emails to
friends family requesting donations and
then instead of
selling something the kids basically
just request the donation and then
they're paying it forward with acts of
kindness assistant principal michelle
thomas student today told me they helped
their
mom make their bed today pta president
stacey johnson it was so fun just to
hear the kids say simple things even
like smile at somebody or go sit next to
somebody who doesn't have a friend to
sit next to you third grader maeve knew
it i like making
colorful
colorful
cards and
making crafts for people fourth grader
liam johnson sometimes i read to my
little sister i only have two sisters
but i tell you what liam i have a couple
of sisters myself
it's hard it's hard to be nice to
yourself
hayes elementary principal lindsay
packer the one thing that really stood
out to me when we were talking about it
today i went into a classroom and asked
the students and he said well i brought
something some chocolate for my teacher
and i said that's wonderful and i said
but how did it make you feel and so
really
instilling the fact that by doing nice
things for people and being kind really
the point is to make you feel good about
it oh so it's called the raise craze
fundraiser for hayes elementary we have
a link to it in the online version of
this story also just for the record for
young liam and all the great folks from
hayes on that zoom call it's not hard to
be nice to my sisters deb and nikki
if you know something that's cool at
school let us know head to
eightnewsnow.com click on the cool at
school that's under the community tab or
you can just send us an email cool at
school at 8newsnow.com